alors bien bien malin celui qui pourrait
prédire le résultat dans montarville on
va suivre avec beaucoup d'intérêt
vous avez certainement suivi hier toute
la journée cette controverse au sujet de
certains votes futur vote étudiant les
gens qui se seraient inscrits de façon
illégale ou qui pourraient s'inscrire de
façon illégale voyez des images de
mathieu vandales il était président de
la commission de révision dans sainte
marie saint jacques il a démissionné en
disant de mouk le processus
d'inscription des nouveaux électeurs ne
lui semblait pas assez clair nous avons
le directeur général des élections avec
nous jacques drouin bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur roy and or monsieur vandal qui
a démissionné et vous en avez
abondamment parlé hier mais lui dit m
choses très simples les règles ne sont
pas aussi clairs que ça alors je vous
pose la question quand on est étudiant
au québec
et qu'ont-ils originaire de l'ontario de
la saskatchewan d'ailleurs à quel moment
on peut voter au québec on peut voter où
québec à partir du moment où on a la
qualité d'électeur je pense que la
notion qualité d'électeur qu'on doit
appliquer si c'est celle du domicile
donc il s'agit pas d'être résident au
québec pendant nos études il faut
décider de venir s'y établir donc cette
notion de domicile qui n'existent pas
vraiment ailleurs ailleurs au canada
mais je tenais à quel moment messieurs
excusez moi à quel moment on considère
qu'un appartement d'étudiant à montréal
devient domicile est-ce que c'est après
six mois automatique
cc oui effectivement c'est six mois de
domicile mais là où la problématique se
situe ses pas sur le nombre de mois
l'heure actuelle c'est beaucoup plus sûr
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un domicile en
2006 une notion de droit qui fait appel
à une intention pour cette intention là
elle doit se manifester par des faits et
pour nous des fêtes quelqu'un qui veut
nous convaincre qu'il est domicilié au
québec ça veut dire qu'il a un compte de
banque au québec qu'il paie ses impôts
au québec qu'un permis de conduire sur
une voiture son premier de conduire est
au québec certificat d'assurance au
québec carte d'assurance-maladie
québécoise
ce sont des éléments qui font que on
prouve que notre intention de s'établir
au québec
oué mais mettons un étudiant qui étudie
un bac une maîtrise à méguet louane
bercy de montréal lui c'est qu'il va
s'en aller après il ya tout à fait droit
s'il veut partir après mais entre-temps
dit moi je juge que je vais pas assez
5,6 cette année au québec pourra-t-il
voter c'est ça ma question
non si pas capable d'établir son
domicile au québec qui pourraient pas
voter au québec parce qu'on ne connaît
pas avec précision les loups avec la loi
électorale ontarienne mais d'après moi
cet électeur le pourrait voter en
ontario ce serait le corps pour des
étudiants qui serait parti du québec
depuis moins de deux ans aurait pu voter
de l'extérieur du québec on en a 18 mai
une personne comme ceux qui vont voter
de l'extérieur du québec aux élections
provinciales qui s'en viennent
alors vous êtes absolument désaccord
avec votre ancien président de
lotissements et saint jacques qui dit le
processus d'inscription les nouveaux
électeurs est flou la notion de domicile
et complexe à définir et suscite des
questions quant à son interprétation en
tout cas lui l'a senti comme ça il y a
des co où lyon s'est pas noir ou blanc
on s'entend c'est tout à fait vrai c'est
un peu juste en train
c'est un dossier complexe à appliquer
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans les
jours qui ont suivi on nous subissons
nous depuis le mardi mercredi dans ces
jours là on a commencé à préparer des
documents pour justement clarifier cette
situation là qui nous était pas arrivé
depuis fort longtemps donc on a produit
des documents qui s'adresse à la
commission de révision qui vient
clarifier comment procéder pour établir
le domicile d'une personne et on a fait
la même chose pour les étudiants ou pour
les personnes qui se présentent en
commission de révision d'accords leur
faire connaître ce que c'est que de
messieurs mais monsieur eu droit en 20
secondes et ce que ja vous disiez il n'y
a pas plus de demandes de
vision qui lie à 18 mois lors de la
dernière élection c'est toujours le cas
c'est toujours le cas c'est moins
d'ailleurs si on prend le global c'est
moins dans les trois circonscriptions
qui sont visés au centre de au
centre-ville de montréal
c'est moins d'électeurs cette année en
date d'hier j'ai pas les chiffres
bien honnêtement je n'ai pas les
chiffres de ce matin jacques drouin
président-directeur de l'élection du
québec merci d'avoir été avec nous fait
plaisir ou sur web endroit